Take a dash of ET, add a pinch of Despicable
Me, Lilo & Stitch, Madagascar, Toy Story,
and a drop of Star Wars, and you get DreamWorks’
colourful and cute animated feature, Home!
Adapted from Adam Rex’s children’s book,
The True Meaning Of Smekday, Home is an odd
couple, culture clash, alien-invasion, road
trip, buddy comedy!
Basically, the film follows what happens when
a cowardly alien race called the Boov head
to Earth to escape their equally alien enemy
the Gorg.
Once on our planet, the Boovs take it over,
relocating all human beings to Australia.
But when an unconventional Boov called Oh
accidentally lets their arch-nemesis know
where they’re hiding, he finds himself on
the run and ends up forming an unlikely friendship
with a young girl called Tip who’s looking
for her relocated mother.
Home doesn’t exactly break new ground, and
while it’s no How To Train Your Dragon or
Shrek, there is still lots to like about DreamWorks’
latest feature.
There’s plenty of zany comedy, much of which
stems from the Boovs’ rather unique uses
for our earthling products which they’ve
never seen before, including hairdryers,
vacuums, oranges, barbecues, and bubble wrap.
The animation itself is bright and colourful,
and will doubtless appeal to kids, and the
overall feel of the movie is fun, and I found
myself laughing quite a bit, though it does
get a touch saccharine towards the end.
There’s also some great voice acting from
the leads.
But, as with Neill Blomkamp’s robot movie
Chappie, how much you enjoy Home will really
depend on whether you warm to the central
character, Oh, who’s voiced by actor Jim
Parsons, best known for playing Sheldon Cooper
in The Big Bang Theory.
The Boov speak in fractured English that has
an intriguing take on our grammar.
For example, Oh says stuff like “You have
in nick time saved us”, and “Can I come
into the out now?” when he wants Tip to
let him out of the fridge she locks him in
when they first meet.
Personally, I thought Jim Parsons’ Sheldon-meets-Yoda-style
performance was pretty engaging.
Pop star Rihanna makes her animated feature
debut as the voice of 12-year-old Tip, and
she invests the character with refreshing
vitality and warmth.
But Rihanna’s role as Tip isn’t the singer’s
only part in the movie.
Her music also makes several appearances on
the soundtrack; as does a song by her on-screen
mother Jennifer Lopez.
Although the tracks are pretty catchy, the
number of them does kinda make it feel like
the movie was made to sell Rihanna’s album.
Tip’s cat, which is called Pig, makes a
cute addition to their little team of two,
even if it does remind me of Tadashi and Hiro’s
cat from Big Hero 6.
And as head Boov, Captain Smek, Steve Martin
brings some animated fun to the proceedings.
We’ve seen the movie’s message about friendship
and individuality many times before in similar
fare, though Home does throw in something
a little different with the idea that the
Boovs who view themselves as the liberators
and friends of the humans they’ve invaded,
are actually seen as quite the opposite by
the earthlings.
So, to sum up: Though Home won’t stay with
you as long as the Toy Storys and Shreks of
the animated world, it is a sweet, colourful
treat that will keep you and the kids entertained
for 90 minutes.
Home gets 3 out of 5 Flicks.
What did you think of Home?
And what’s your favourite animated movie
& why?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this video, hit the thumbs-up
button & subscribe for my weekly movie reviews
and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!